I've got some breaking news to bring you  right now a 22 year old man has in the  past few minutes been charged with the  murder of nine-year-old Lilia valatite  who you'll recall was stabbed in Boston  in Lincolnshire on Thursday evening  police arrested their suspect yesterday  afternoon in Boston at Central Park not  actually that far from the murder scene  and tonight Lincolnshire police have  told us that 22 year old David ass  skabass has been charged with murder we  believe he will appear in court tomorrow  he's currently being held in custody so  that's an update to the Fatal stabbing  of nine-year-old Lilia valatite in  Boston a 22 year old man David skebas  has in the past few minutes been charged  with murder